if I was six foot four and ran like a
gazelle I'd play for the Jets instead of
owning them I really need everybody to
have that one sink in cuz it's the most
important one you know like when you're
driving and the cop lights go on and
that your [ __ ] heart goes but then
when they when the cop drives by you're
like goof you feel real good and then
you start driving with two hands and the
speed limit for about four minutes and
then you get back to being like
ridiculous that's how people live in
their lives right like grandma gets sick
or mom has a cancer scare or they get
sick or something and then they get to
start caring about real [ __ ] nobody's
given a [ __ ] about a supreme backpack
when your health isn't going anywhere
and so I just don't understand why
people are living their lives like that
and so [ __ ] gratitude we've got the
whole game miss framed everybody's
confused people talking about millions
as like I got to make a million that's
like an entry point and they don't even
understand that 99% of people in America
don't make four hundred thousand dollars
a year nobody is putting on marathon
sneakers everybody wants to be a
sprinter everybody wants it tomorrow
a lot of people taking money and instead
of investing it back into their business
buying dumb [ __ ] and that's why I
[ __ ] put scrutiny on everybody who's
trying to do you know courses and
pre-rolls try to get you to pay four
thousand for this and ten thousand oh
that's like this [ __ ] is simple all the
information is free there's a lot of
people who'd much rather much rather pay
somebody to make them feel good about
why they're not doing let me give you
the secret once and for all right here
work a lot everybody looks at the people
that made it and none of you looked at
how they got there talk your truth
create a framework that you can [ __ ]
follow talk your reality think about
your [ __ ] grandparents then have no
internet that'll work the job and go to
sleep
the fact that you can work your
nine-to-five to pay off your debt or pay
your rent or take care of what you have
to and then you can take on your phone
and [ __ ] work from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00
in the morning that's a [ __ ] blessing
that's a [ __ ] opportunity and nobody
can stop you and nobody decides but us
it's [ __ ] crazy do you have the
community to put in the [ __ ] work
period because the only people listening
to your excuses for your [ __ ] are
your loser [ __ ] friends my friends
let's just get to the punchline nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your problems people
sit in little circles with four people
everybody gassing each other up to not
do [ __ ] people complain in downstairs
blaring $213 shoes shut the [ __ ] up like
your perspective the [ __ ] do you think
is going on in the world everybody's
pointing at everybody else with that
other standing oh please deploy empathy
here's what you don't get you [ __ ]
lack patience too many of you talk about
being in but you're not living it you
know why you guys are patient cuz you
want to win already to [ __ ] stick it
to your [ __ ] parents I'm trying to
become your excuse your shield your
thing that you can point to because if
you trip and fall you guys are worried
about failing and I'm trying to get you
to point at me and blame me that it
didn't work versus blaming yourself so
that it gives you the courage to
actually start doing [ __ ] but you've got
our sin instead of sitting here and
dwelling and blaming them you're in
control of your own [ __ ] you got one
[ __ ] that bad
do something with it listen some of you
been consuming this for a year or two
you watch those videos on Instagram or
YouTube watch my blog or listen that you
get listen to podcast you get hyped you
get hyped and you're like right and then
you stop listening and you walk out into
your real life and you go back to dumb
[ __ ] you know me people sitting here
still dwelling about some dumb [ __ ] that
happened in 2011 it's binary this whole
thing your [ __ ] life is binary let me
tell you what you should focus on you
need to do some [ __ ] you like if I could
ever convince all of you that your
shortcomings and your detriment are your
strengths you would win you guys want to
be selfless and be good and give back be
selfish first to get your [ __ ] to the
place where you need to be the current
state of political correctness and how
you should parent how you should live
what age you should get marry that like
that's all [ __ ] like it's there's
only one story like yours I'm not scared
of losing because I don't allow any of
you to judge me guys are only scared to
lose cuz you're worried about what other
people gonna say my losses are my losses
you